This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。有血有肉的人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目主要探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他地方真的不太安全、无法开展的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的、有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向世界传输出一种信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就非得去这么做，听听就明白了。
Turn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》（The Hard Way）。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇特现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。《2%》（That's TWO.%）。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。去听听《闺蜜》吧。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·恩格利斯（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》（Look Back at It）。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're talking the psychology of routines. What is it about morning routines and nighttime routines and daily routines that people just swear by and not just in their 20s but throughout life? You know, parents who swear by routine for their children, 60 year olds, 70 year olds who seem like they are the happiest people in the world because they have routine. And is it really as simple as having a morning waking time? or some general activity scheduled in your day,
新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪一个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是20多岁人群的心理学。今天，我们要聊的是日常规律（routines）的心理学。为什么人们对早晨的习惯、晚上的习惯以及日常规律如此笃信不疑，而且不仅仅是在20多岁的时候，而是一生都在坚持？你知道的，父母对孩子的生活规律深信不疑，60岁、70岁的老人似乎也是世界上最快乐的人，因为他们生活有规律。这真的就像拥有一个早晨起床时间那么简单吗？还是在你的日程里安排一些常规活动？
could that be the simple answer to making us happier? Turns out there is a lot of evidence for routine, but also some downsides, some controversies that we're going to talk about on today's episode. I am going to start out by being entirely honest with you all. I am by no means, someone who claims to be an expert in productivity or routine for that matter. you know, if I had to choose between productivity and discipline or creativity and spontaneity, I would most of the time choose creativity and spontaneity almost every day. But I have come around to the idea and I have been convinced that routine allows for both
难道这就是让我们更快乐的简单答案吗？事实证明，有大量证据支持规律作息的好处，但它也有一些缺点和争议，我们将在今天的节目中讨论这些。我首先要对大家完全坦诚。我绝不是什么自称在生产力或规律作息方面的大师。你知道的，如果让我在生产力和纪律性，与创造力和随性之间做选择，大多数时候我几乎每天都会选择创造力和随性。但我后来转念一想，并且确信：规律作息其实能兼顾这两者。
in, you know, a way that actually lets you get the most out of what you want from life, even if it seems opposed to something that requires rigidity and strictness. And I have also realized in my own life that when I have structure, I feel better, I operate better, I have much greater clarity and focus. That is one side of the benefits that routine brings. You know, it brings a great reduction to anxiety. It brings greater time management, just to name a few. And a recent study looking at over 1,000 individuals has even suggested that people who have
而且，它能让你以一种真正能从生活中获得你想要的东西的方式去生活，尽管它看起来似乎与那些需要死板和严格的事情相违背。我也在自己的生活中意识到，当我有了结构和框架时，我感觉更好，运作得更好，我有更好的清晰度和专注力。这就是规律带来的好处的一面。你知道的，它能极大地减少焦虑。它能带来更好的时间管理，这只是其中几个例子。最近一项针对1,000多名个体的研究甚至表明，那些拥有
the morning routine, they typically earn more. They are happier. They have more fulfilling relationships even. So that is something that we need to most certainly look into. And I think even those things alone might persuade most of us who are on the fence to maybe start incorporating some rituals, some non-negotiables and some protocols into our life. So we're going to talk about all of that today, why routine is so good for our brains, why our brains crave it, and the routines of some of the most successful people in the world, and what we can take from those routines to apply to our own lives in a small and more sustainable way. I also want to talk about three very important tips for creating a routine that you will actually stick with. Tips,
晨间习惯的人，通常收入更高。他们更快乐。甚至拥有更充实的人际关系。所以这绝对是我们需要深入研究的课题。而且我认为，仅凭这些好处，就可能说服我们大多数处于观望状态的人，开始在生活中融入一些仪式感、一些不容妥协的原则和一些行为准则。所以我们今天要讨论所有这些：为什么规律对我们的大脑这么好、为什么我们的大脑渴望规律，以及世界上一些最成功人士的日常作息，还有我们可以从这些作息中汲取什么，以一种微小且更可持续的方式应用到我们自己的生活中。我还想讨论创造一个你真正能坚持下去的规律的三个非常重要的秘诀。这些秘诀，
I'm guessing you probably haven't heard before, but also how to balance the needs. for spontaneity and the need for novelty with a desire for structure. It's a big episode. One that I think I'll probably end up coming back to myself. But as always, I hope that we learn something together. I hope that you find the psychology and the research fascinating. Without further ado, let's get into the episode. Routine is quite a broad term. So not to sound too simplistic in like a textbook, but I do want to give kind of a guideline around what this generally means, what we're talking about today. My definition of routine is that it is a series of habits that benefit your lifestyle
我猜你以前可能没听过，同时还要讨论如何在对随性和新鲜感的需求与对结构框架的渴望之间取得平衡。这是一个内容丰富的节目。我想我最后可能自己也会回听。但和往常一样，我希望我们能一起学到东西。我希望你会觉得其中的心理学和研究引人入胜。废话不多说，让我们进入正题吧。日常规律是一个相当广泛的术语。所以为了不显得太简单、太像教科书，我还是想为这究竟意味着什么、我们今天在讨论什么设定一个大致的框架。我对日常规律的定义是：它是一系列有益于你生活方式的习惯，
that are repeated on a regular basis, so in the morning, evening, daily, weekly, monthly, and these habits have to be intentional. So, you know, most people eat breakfast. That doesn't necessarily mean that it's a deliberate and specific routine. You have to be intentional with it, you know, putting a specific behavior at a time that corresponds best to your lifestyle, and you have to believe that it's going to help you in some area of your life. I think if someone was going to ask me for a definition, that's the best I can come up with. Now, routine. Routines have been applauded by people all over the globe from all disciplines, from athletes to entertainers, business leaders, politicians, parents, students, you will find an example in every single domain
这些习惯是定期重复的，比如在早晨、傍晚、每天、每周、每月，而且这些习惯必须是有意为之的。所以，你知道的，大多数人都吃早餐。但这并不一定意味着它是一个深思熟虑的、特定的规律。你必须对它抱有刻意的态度，你知道的，把特定的行为安排在最符合你生活方式的时间里，而且你必须相信它会在生活的某个领域对你有所帮助。我想如果有人向我要一个定义，这就是我能想到的最好的回答了。好了，关于规律。来自全球各地、各个领域的各界人士都对规律赞不绝口，从运动员到艺人、商界领袖、政治家、父母、学生，你会在每一个领域找到
of a routine that people swear by. And people who will, you know, very readily tell you that it has changed their life. And there is a real fascination with what do successful people do in their day that sets them apart from other people. There's thousands of YouTube videos, thousands of articles, probably hundreds of books written on this very subject. But to keep it small, more. The reason that people love routine, specifically the routines they've created for themselves, but really any form of routine in general, is that it does for our brain what the modern world simply cannot. It provides structure and it provides a sense of predictability that makes us feel safe and secure. As much as our brain does like novelty and we crave new experience. We crave new
人们笃信不疑的规律。而且总会有人很乐意告诉你，它改变了他们的生活。人们对成功人士在日常生活中做了什么、究竟是什么让他们与其他人区分开来，有着一种真正的着迷。关于这个主题，有成千上万的 YouTube 视频、成千上万篇文章，可能还有数百本书。但为了化繁为简。人们热爱规律，特别是他们为自己创造的规律，以及实际上任何形式的规律的原因在于，它为我们的大脑做到了现代世界根本做不到的事情。它提供了结构，并提供了一种让我们感到安全和稳妥的可预测感。尽管我们的大脑确实喜欢新鲜感，我们也渴望新的体验。我们渴望新的
experiences, things that are surprising, even the best kinds of surprises, even the good stuff, that actually still causes us stress. That's the interesting thing about stress. A lot of people think that it's this negative nasty thing. Stress just means arousal. They can be good stress, there can be bad stress. It still puts pressure on the body. But when we have a routine, that kind of eases that necessary stress that we encounter in our daily life. by allowing us to almost switch off our brain for the routine stuff for like the normal stuff we do day to day and to save our cognitive resources for the surprising things good and bad and to make sure that you know we give our brain rest so that it doesn't have to make as many decisions throughout
体验，渴望那些令人惊讶的事物，甚至是最好的那种惊喜，哪怕是好事，其实仍然会给我们带来压力。这就是压力有趣的地方。很多人认为这是一个消极的、讨厌的东西。压力只意味着唤醒。它有好压力，也有坏压力。它依然会对身体施加压力。但当我们有了规律时，它就能通过以下方式缓解我们在日常生活中遇到的那种必要压力：它几乎允许我们在处理常规事情（比如我们日复一日做的那些正常事情）时让大脑“关机”，从而把我们的认知资源留给那些带来惊喜的好事和坏事，并确保你知道，我们让大脑得到休息，这样它就不必在一天中做出那么多的决定，
our day it can find comfort and stability in the patterns and habits that we have rehearsed Basically, like I said, with so much chaos going on, routine is like a nice cozy bed. It's like a nice home to go home to. I think the biggest evidence for why routines work and why they help us is how much they actually alleviate anxiety. And how much it removes so many of the unknowns that anxiety and negative stress really thrives on. So there's this 2002 research paper that I read for this episode. that basically concluded that those of us who lack routine, we essentially leave the door open for more minor disruptions. And those minor disruptions can snowball into ongoing and chronic stress,
它可以在我们反复排练过的模式和习惯中找到安慰和稳定性。基本上，正如我所说，在有这么多混乱的情况下，规律就像一张舒适的床。就像一个可以回到的温馨的家。我认为，关于规律为什么有效、为什么能帮助我们，最有力的证据就是它们在多大程度上真正减轻了焦虑。以及它消除了多少焦虑和负面压力得以滋生的未知因素。所以，我为这期节目读了一篇2002年的研究论文，
but also more persistent and probable anxiety. I will say, like I said before, the times I have been most routine bound have been the days that I feel more at peace. I wake up with less sense of urgency, I have less thoughts running through my head, I don't face as much choice overload. Routine is this very beautiful way of allowing us to explore and be creative and be big thinkers, whilst also knowing that we have something to ground us. So there's two words there that I think are really crucial for understanding the benefits of routine. It's certainty and it's grounding. Those are the two really important components and we can probably add a final word in here and that is efficiency. So certainty grounding efficiency. So a 2016 paper from Harvard Business School,
该论文基本上得出结论：我们当中缺乏规律的人，本质上是为更多的微小干扰敞开了大门。而这些微小干扰可能会滚雪球般演变成持续的、慢性的压力，以及更持久、更可能的焦虑。我得说，正如我之前所说的那样，我生活最有规律的那些时期，正是我感觉最平静的日子。我醒来时没有那么强的紧迫感，我脑子里盘旋的杂念更少了，我不会面临那么多的选择过载。规律是一种非常美妙的方式，它既能允许我们探索、发挥创造力并成为宏大的思考者，同时又让我们知道我们有某种东西作为根基。所以这里有两个词，我认为对于理解规律的好处至关重要。一个是确定性，一个是根基。这是两个非常重要的组成部分，我们可能还可以在这里加上最后一个词，那就是效率。所以，确定性、根基、效率。那么，哈佛商学院2016年的一篇论文，
just to float another study out there for you, they found that by decreasing anxiety, which we know is what routine does, rituals, routines, protocols, they improved mental performance and they improve cognitive performance as well, because they become a way for us to get the most out of our hours by really streamlining processes at critical time periods. So in the morning or the evening, there's a lot that needs to get done in those opening and closing shifts. And it can quickly consume our whole day if we don't use our time in the limited hours we have in those pockets of time most efficiently. That's what routine does. You know, if you have a solid morning routine, you don't have to set your alarm every night for what time you want to wake up.
顺便再提一下另一项研究，他们发现，通过减少焦虑（我们知道这就是规律的作用），仪式、规律和行为准则能够提升心理表现和认知表现，因为它们成了一种方式，让我们通过在关键时间段简化流程，来充分利用我们的时间。因此，在早晨或傍晚，在这些开盘和收盘的交接班时间里，有很多事情需要完成。如果我们不能最有效地利用我们拥有的有限时间，这些事情就会迅速吞噬我们的一整天。这就是规律的作用。你知道的，如果你有一个扎实的早晨规律，你就不必每天晚上都去设定第二天早上想几点醒来的闹钟，
you've already done it. You know what time it will be. You don't have to think about what you're going to have for breakfast every morning. You don't have to calculate when you can squeeze in a workout. It's all laid out for you like this gift from a prior version of you who thought, okay, let's just make this all a little bit smoother. Let's make this a little bit easier, more effortless. Routine and allocating dedicated time slots for specific tasks have also been shown to make us more productive, obviously, because we have a distinct time period where something needs to get done, that really increases focus and what we call task-based urgency, meaning that if you have 15 minutes that you put aside every day to do something, you are more likely to use that time for the desired activity.
你已经定好了。你知道那时会是几点。你不需要去想每天早上要吃什么早餐。你不需要计算什么时候能挤出时间锻炼。这一切都为你安排好了，就像来自过去的你的礼物，那个过去的你心想：“好吧，让我们把这一切变得更顺畅一点。让我们把它变得更容易、更不费力一点。”规律以及为特定任务分配专门的时间段，也被证明能让我们更具生产力，显然是因为我们有一个明确的时间段来完成某项任务，这确实能增强专注力以及我们所谓的基于任务的紧迫感，这意味着如果你每天抽出15分钟去做某件事，你更有可能把这15分钟用在期望的活动上。
You're less likely to compromise, and that actually means that you'll achieve more, but also you'll be happier because if you can streamline kind of the annoying things, the admin tasks of life, the brushing of the teeth, the showering, like the admin emails, you do end up having more time to just be a human, to enjoy yourself, to have fun. And those benefits, they are not sequestered by age. They don't disappear, you know, at a certain age. It doesn't take a specific time or age for them to start.
你更不可能妥协，这实际上意味着你会取得更多成就，而且你会更快乐，因为如果你能简化生活中的那些烦人事、行政任务——比如刷牙、洗澡、处理日常邮件——你最终确实会有更多的时间去纯粹地做一个人，去享受生活，去获得乐趣。而且这些好处并不会被年龄所局限。它们不会在某个特定年龄就消失。它们的开始并不需要特定的时间和年龄。
So maybe I should explain this in a better way. Basically, routine benefits everyone. I came across a really cool paper while researching this episode from 2018 and it talks about how good routine is for children specifically and how there are some pediatricians and some teachers who can tell the kids that have a bedtime, who have a dinner time, who have homework or family time compared to those who don't and those kids are typically more resilient, they're less stressed and they have better attention spans. So when we take that same logic into adulthood, you know, when we are adults, we don't have a parent telling us to do. We are the primary grown up in our lives being like, okay, I'm going to be a little bit strict with myself here and I'm going to allocate certain times. I'm going to create routine. Those same structures that helped us as children will continue to help us as adults. This is specifically the case when life feels naturally or like contextually very stressful.
所以也许我应该用更好的方式来解释这一点。基本上，规律对每个人都有好处。在为这期节目做研究时，我偶然看到了一篇非常棒的2018年的论文，它讨论了规律对儿童具体有多好，以及有些儿科医生和老师能分辨出哪些孩子有就寝时间、有晚餐时间、有做作业或家庭时间，而哪些孩子没有；那些孩子通常更具韧性，压力更小，注意力持续时间更长。所以，当我们把同样的逻辑带入成年期时，你知道，当我们成年后，没有父母会告诉我们要去做什么。我们是自己生活中的主要成年人，我们会对自己说：“好吧，我要对自己严格一点，我要分配好特定的时间。我要建立规律。”那些在小时候帮助过我们的结构，在成年后会继续帮助我们。当生活自然而然地或情境上感觉压力非常大时，这种情况尤其明显。
Like whenever I get DMs from people being like, I'm so overwhelmed at uni, I've just been through this huge breakup and I feel like the world is crumbling underneath me. I always say you need to start practicing some kind of grounding ritual or routine for yourself. You need to lower the cognitive burden of even the most minute decision-making tasks because your brain needs all the stability that it can get during exam periods, during resum periods, during difficult emotional times, if you can just make some things more automatic, that gives you more time to process and to think and to be able to problem solve. So I hope that's just like big mound of evidence that I've just thrown at you has made a compelling case. You know, it's evidence that I probably need to relisten to myself at times. I need to stop scheduling meetings at 8am during my morning routine. I need to find a dedicated time to work out because it's
就像每当我收到人们的私信说：“我在大学里感到不知所措，我刚刚经历了一场巨大的分手，我觉得世界正在我脚下崩塌”时，我总是说，你需要开始为自己练习某种根基性的仪式或规律。你需要降低哪怕是最小的决策任务所带来的认知负担，因为你的大脑在考试期间、在简历投递期间、在困难的情感时期，需要它所能获得的所有稳定性；如果你能让某些事情变得更加自动化，这就给你更多的时间去处理、去思考并能够解决问题。所以我希望我刚才抛出的这一大堆证据能构成一个令人信服的论点。你知道，这些证据也是我有时自己需要重新聆听的。我需要停止在早晨规律期间把会议安排在早上8点。我需要找一个专用的时间来锻炼，因为这
It's always the last thing on my list for the day. Like, I definitely need to have a better bedtime. But consider me, like, an imperfect version of success or adherence here. Like, do better than me. But also, it's hopefully an example. Like, hopefully you can use my life as an example of how even just going forward imperfectly with your routine, although those things routine and imperfect, like, sound contradictory, like, if you can just show up as often as possible in your desired routine,
总是排在我每天清单上的最后一位。就像，我绝对需要一个更好的就寝时间。但请把我当成成功或坚持的不完美版本吧。做个比我更好的人。但同时，它也希望是一个例子。希望你能把我的生活当作一个例子，看看哪怕只是带着不完美继续执行你的规律——尽管“规律”和“不完美”听起来有些矛盾——如果你能尽可能频繁地在你的期望规律中出场，
your life does get better. All right, let's talk about some of the most effective routines in the world. What do some of the most successful people on this planet do in their mornings, evenings, evenings, afternoons, and nights? Some of these are rather intense, I will say. I love hearing people's morning routines, but there are times when I'm like, wow, like 4 a.m., wake up, you get all of that done before you even have lunch. Like, how am I even able to compare?
你的生活确实会变得更好。好了，让我们来聊聊世界上一些最有效的规律。这个星球上一些最成功的人士在他们的早晨、傍晚、下午和夜晚都在做些什么？我得说，其中一些相当极端。我喜欢听别人的早晨规律，但有时我会想：“哇，比如凌晨4点醒来，你在吃午饭前就把所有这些都做完了。这让我怎么比？”
We will be taking small lessons from these routines. Please don't consider these as, like, options for you to choose from. I think they're just very, very fascinating. So with that in mind, let's start with Barack Obama, former president of the United States. So he would reportedly wake up at 7 a.m. every morning. Honestly, 7 a.m. is pretty early, in my mind, but kind of later than I thought a president would wake up, but that's what he does, 7 a.m. He would work out six days a week for 45 minutes.
我们将从这些规律中汲取一些微小的教训。请不要把这些当作供你挑选的选项。我认为它们只是非常、非常迷人。带着这个想法，让我们从美国前总统贝拉克·奥巴马（Barack Obama）开始。据报道，他每天早上7点醒来。老实说，在我看来，早上7点已经相当早了，但比我原本以为总统醒来的时间要晚一些，不过他就是这么做的，7点。他会一周锻炼六天，每次45分钟。
He apparently told his aides that the rest of my time will be more productive if you give me my workout time, which that's a man who prioritizes. He would then have breakfast with his family if he was like in the White House, which we love a family man. Then this is a really beautiful part of his routine. He would then walk one minute to his office in the Oval Office because, of course, he lived in the White House. and he said that was like his thinking time that was like almost a meditation a one minute solo walk to work basically where he would just allow himself to just breathe think imagine do whatever a president does i guess with that time i think that's just a really really
他显然曾对助手说：“如果你们给我锻炼的时间，我其余的时间就会更有成效。”这真是一个懂得优先排序的男人。如果他身处白宫，他就会和家人共进早餐，我们太喜欢顾家的男人了。接下来这是他规律中非常美好的一部分。他会步行一分钟走到他的办公室——椭圆形办公室，因为他当然住在白宫里。他说那就像是他的思考时间，几乎就像是一场冥想：一段独自走到办公室的漫步，只需一分钟，在那里他只是让自己呼吸、思考、想象，我想总统在那个时间大概就是做这些吧。我认为这对于当时身处那个位置的人来说，真的是一个非常、非常
simple routine for someone who was at the time you know like the busiest of most influential person in the world but what i like about it was that it was predictable it's easy to follow and it's not like as intense as you would imagine. Let's talk about Anna Winter's routine, obviously the editor-in-chief of Vogue. Now she apparently wakes up at 5.45 a.m. And then she plays tennis for an hour on the dot, finishing at 7. So she says this keeps it physically fit. It also helps her sharpen her focus.
简单的规律，当时他是世界上最忙碌、最具影响力的人物。但我喜欢它的地方在于它是可预测的、容易遵循的，而且不像你想象的那么极端。让我们来谈谈安娜·温图尔（Anna Wintour）的规律，显然她是《Vogue》的主编。据报道，她早上5点45分醒来。然后她准时打一个小时的网球，7点结束。所以她说这能让她保持身体健美。这也帮助她磨炼专注力。
And then following her game, she spends the next hour and a half in hair and makeup. And she does it every day. She says it's like ensures that she is ready for her. demanding schedule. I think if you were like someone who wears makeup, you understand this feeling. I remember like when I was at uni, I would do a full face of makeup every single day before I left my dorm room before I went to class. And some of my friends would be like, that seems a little bit unnecessary, but I was like, this is meditative. This is a way to just be like, I'm present with myself for 20 minutes, 30 minutes, doing this like ritual of like paint.
在打完球之后，她会花一个半小时做发型和化妆。她每天都这么做。她说这能确保她为自己高强度的工作日程做好准备。我想如果你是个化妆的人，你就能理解这种感觉。我记得当我上大学时，每天离开宿舍去上课之前，我都会化全妆。我的一些朋友会觉得这有点没必要，但我当时觉得：这是具有冥想性质的。这是一种方式，让我花20分钟、30分钟与自己共处，进行这种给我脸上色的仪式，让我觉得自己presentable（得体），这确实会影响我一整天的心情，我觉得这非常特别。让我们聊一个不寻常的例子。我们已经看过了两个看似相当干脆利落、将锻炼置于首位、且非常忙碌的人，接下来是吉姆·凯瑞（Jim Carrey）。我们来聊聊他的规律。一位非常著名的喜剧演员。显然他有一个这样的日常仪式：每天早上11点，他会给自己打电话，假装是过去某个人打来电话告诉他一些消息，或者打来电话对他说些什么，他每天都会想出一个新的角色，这就像是一个创作练习，好让他的灵感迸发。所以你看。这又是一个规律可以非常契合你自身的例子。我想再谈谈另一个著名的
my face and like making myself feel presentable that does influence how I feel for the rest of the day, which I think is really special. Let's talk about an unusual one. We've had two that seem like pretty cut and dry, like exercise as a priority, very busy people, Jim Carrey. Let's talk about his routine. Very famous comedian. Apparently he has just this one daily ritual that at 11 a.m. every single day, he calls himself and he pretends that it's someone from the past calling him with some news or calling him to tell him something and he comes up with a new character every single day and it's like a creative exercise for him to like get the juices flowing. So there you go. There's another example of how it can be very much suited to who you are. I want to touch on one more famous
早晨规律。你可能以前听说过。那是安德鲁·休伯曼（Andrew Huberman）关于清晨的著名仪式。所以安德鲁·休伯曼是一位神经科学家。你可能在《休伯曼实验室》（Huberman Lab）听过他的节目。我得说，我并不一定赞同这个男人所说的一切，但他的早晨规律绝对很有趣、很有启发性，而且根据他自己的研究，具有极高的生产力。所以我们来聊聊这个。他的早晨规律包括在习惯醒来的时间之前两到三个小时醒来。所以我们大多数人都有，很明显，我们有昼夜节律，我们有生物钟。我们大多数人都有一个自然醒来的时间。你知道，我知道对我来说，大概是8点左右。那就是我的
morning routine. You've probably heard of it before. It's Andrew. Huberman's very famous ritual for his early mornings. So Andrew Huberman, he is a neuroscientist. You may have listened to him on the Huberman Lab. I will say, I don't necessarily agree with everything that the man has to say, but his morning routine is definitely interesting, definitely provocative, and according to his own research, highly productive. So let's talk about it. So his morning routine consists of waking up two to three hours before you habitually wake up. So most of us have, obviously we have circadian rhythm, we have a body clock. Most of us have a time that we would naturally like to wake up at. You know, I know for me, it's around 8 o'clock. Like that's when
身体在说：“好了，我们醒了。”如果我超过那个时间睡过头，我总是会觉得有点昏昏沉沉。如果我起得更早，我总是会觉得有点勉强，我得真的把自己从床上拽起来。他说这其实是一件好事。在习惯醒来的时间之前两到三个小时起床，然后补充水分，喝500毫升水，接受10到30分钟的晨光照射。如果你的居住地早晨非常黑，这一条就有点难了。就像，你知道的，如果你正常的醒来时间是8点，而你必须在6点或5点起床，而太阳直到9点才升起，这听起来有点像是加州人的做法，但我们继续。然后你要锻炼至少40
my body is like, all right, we're awake. If I oversleep past that time, I always feel a little bit groggy. If I get up earlier, I'm always a little bit like, I have to really pull myself out of bed. He says that's a good thing. Get up two to three hours before you would habitually wake up, then hydrate, drink 500 mils of water, get 10 to 30 minutes of morning light exposure. This one's a bit hard like if you live somewhere that's really dark in the mornings. Like, you know, if your normal wake-up time is 8 and you have to wake up at 6 or 5 and the sun doesn't rise till 9, this seems like a bit of a Californian thing, but let's keep going. Then you want to exercise for at least 40
分钟，40分钟，一周三到四次，做有氧运动或力量训练，洗个澡，然后在午餐前或者就在清晨的这段时间里进行90分钟的专注工作。显然，90分钟意味着你应该能够坐下来，把那些清晨的事情一口气做完。然后他在下午也有一个安排，那就是进行10到30分钟的非睡眠深度休息（NSDR）、催眠或者小睡，
minutes, 40 minutes, three to four times a week, either cardio or weight training, shower, and then you do 90 minutes of focused work before lunch or like just in that first early morning bit. 90 minutes apparently that's like you should be able to sit down and just knock out all those early morning things. And then he has something for his afternoon as well, which is he does like 10 to 30 minutes of non-sleep deep rest or hypnosis or a napnosis or a nap. and then he gets 10 to 15 minutes of evening light exposure. Intensive. Some key points to this.
接着他会接受10到15分钟的晚间光照。强度很大。这里面有几个关键点。他的重点似乎在于提高机敏度，与自己的身体保持高度连接。他还有一个做法，就是在醒来后大约一个半小时内推迟摄入咖啡因。所以真的让我们的身体通过光照和补水来进行自然调节，这（你知道的）确实能为身体做好准备，并刺激许多神经调节物质，从而提高全天的唤醒水平和精神敏锐度。这是一件好事。但如果我们全面地来看所有这些规律，它们确实有一个共同点。它们都围绕着对那个人最重要的事情以及一个不可妥协的核心展开，无论是锻炼、
His focus really seems on streamlining alertness, being very in touch with his body. He also has this thing of like delaying caffeine intake by like an hour and a half after you wake up. So really letting our bodies naturally regulate through light exposure, through hydration, which, you know, really does prepare the body and it stimulates a lot of neuromodulators and increase arousal and mental acuity throughout the day. It's a good thing. But if we're going to look at all of these routines holistically, they do have one thing in common. They all revolve around the thing that is most important to that person and a singular non-negotiable, whether it's exercise, whether it's
化妆、机敏度，还是一个电话。这些优先级向我表明的是价值观。它们契合了那个人的价值观。是家庭、创造力、自信、精神清晰度，还是身体健康？这就引出了一个问题，对吧？在所有这些例子中，是否存在一个最好的规律？其中一个是最好的吗？答案其实比你想象的要复杂一些。我们将在短暂的休息后讨论所有这些以及更多内容，请不要离开。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇特现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与
makeup, whether it is alertness, whether it is a phone call. And what those like priorities indicate to me are values. They suit the person's values. Is it family, creativity, confidence, mental clarity, physical health? And that kind of leads me to the question, right? Is there a best routine of all these examples is one of them best? And the answer is, you know, a little bit more complicated than you would think. We're going to talk about all of that and more stay with us after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with
作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的那些陈词滥调和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier（更健康）的人。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple 播客上收听《2%》。
writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the in-crashire and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
或在你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击金·卡戴珊（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟金·卡戴珊到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·恩格利斯（Alex English）。
or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English.
每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要明确的是，84年对我的意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用上收听《回看当年》，
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
播客，或在任何你获取播客的地方。欢迎收听我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师克尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在盯着记分牌看，生活变成了赢与输的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，当你活在世上时，还是说你成为一个好人是因为你感到害怕？因为那是
podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses steve burns dustin ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's
兄弟，这是两种截然不同的动机。绝对是这样，那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地去成为一个好人。和我——克尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）
two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust i want you to just really be a good person join me keir gains is we have real conversations about healing growth fatherhood pressure and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显破绽。这开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of
互联网侦探来侦破此案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·亚历斯宾（Greg Alesbian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
Internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IheartRadio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Amaricopa County as, Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新一季的《闺蜜》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像是被卡车撞了。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们自己采取行动。我说：“哦，见鬼，才不呢。”我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
完美的规律。答案是：没有。并没有一个能对所有人完美奏效的通用规律，但规律中确实包含一些元素，绝对会对你有所帮助。而且这样的规律也将触及我们想要瞄准的几个核心健康支柱。首先，如果你要开始建立规律，选择早晨或傍晚。这是用好习惯将你的一天“装订”起来的绝佳方式。所以我觉得工作，你知道的，一个中午的规律或者工作日的规律有点复杂，需要付出很多努力。
A perfect routine. The answer is no. There is not a universal routine that is going to work perfectly for everyone, but there are ingredients to a routine that will most certainly help you. And also a routine that will hit some of those core pillars of health that we want to target. it. Firstly, if you're going to start with a routine, choose either the morning or the evening. This is an amazing way to bookend your day with good habits. So I feel like a work, you know, a midday routine or a workday routine is a little bit complicated and takes a lot of effort.
但你的晚间规律和早晨规律，它们通常只需要大约一个小时或一个半小时。所以这确实是你应该开始专注的地方。我认为，你知道的，你的早晨规律定下了基调，但你的夜间规律给你这一天的最后回味。它允许恢复。无论你选择哪一个，取决于你选择哪一个，这些规律中每一个都需要围绕着与睡眠相关的事情、与运动相关的事情，以及会让你的生活更轻松的事情展开。例如，为第二天摆好衣服，写感恩日记，醒来后30分钟内或睡前30分钟内不玩手机。最有效的规律包含上述至少两项，并且在扩展之前从小事做起。
But your evening and your morning routine, they kind of only take like an hour or an hour of half. So that's really where you should begin to focus. I think, you know, your morning routine sets the tone, but your night routine gives you the last taste of the day. It allows for restoration. Whatever one you choose, depending on which you choose, what each of these routines need to be centered around is something to do with sleep, something to do with movement, and something that is going to make your life easier. So for example, laying out your outfit for the next day, gratitude you're journaling, not going on your phone 30 minutes after you wake up or 30 minutes before bed. Most effective routines contain at least two of the above and they start small before expanding.
你知道的，在此之后，有些人可能会加入用餐时间、液体补充、洗澡、化妆，或者任何你觉得需要做的事情。它的结构首先围绕着小事情展开，我们等会儿会讨论为什么这很重要。有一件事我真的觉得，如果你更专注于建立一个日常规律，而不是一开始就设置一个特定的大块时间日程表，相反，我希望你考虑的是一个检查清单式的规律，而不是一个具体的时间规律。在我看来，你的日常规律检查清单应该优先考虑以下五件事：
You know, after that some people might add in meal times, liquid, showering, makeup, whatever it is that, you know, you feel needs to be done. It is structured around, firstly, things that are small and we're going to talk about why that's important. something that I really think if you are more focused on creating like a daily routine instead of setting up like a specific time blocking agenda to begin with instead I want you to kind of think about a checklist routine instead of like a specific time routine and it's my opinion that your daily checklist your daily routine checklist should prioritize these five things something for your health something productive something for your mental health
对健康有益的事、有成效的事、对心理健康有益的事、社交方面的事以及纯粹为你自己的事。所以：健康、生产力、心理、社交、纯粹为你自己。如果你想触及我们生活中幸福的五个支柱，你也可以在其中加入灵性。这些就是我会重点关注的方面。所以，早上健身，一坐在办公桌前就写下待办事项清单，10分钟冥想，和朋友吃午餐或晚餐，然后看我最喜欢的节目或在睡前做一些手工。
something for you socially and something just for you. So health, productivity, mental, social, just for you. If you want to hit the five pillars of happiness in our life, you may also include spirituality in there. Those are the ones that I would be focusing on. So gym in the morning, writing out a to-do list as soon as I sit down at my desk, 10 minutes of meditation, seeing friends for lunch or dinner, and then watching my favorite show or doing something crafty before bed.
既有社交方面的满足，也有纯粹属于你自己的享受。所以包括健康、工作效率、心理健康、社交以及自我关怀。如果你想在生活中达到幸福的五大支柱，你甚至可以把灵性也包括进去。这些就是我会专注于实现的方面。所以早上健身，一坐在办公桌前就写出待办事项清单，进行10分钟的冥想，中午或晚上和朋友见面，然后在睡前看我最喜欢的节目或者做一些手工艺。
Like that is the perfect day that involves specific protocols I know will make me happy. It also makes sense that like when we're talking about choosing routine, different routines are going to work for different professions, different personalities, different people. So if you are someone who works night shifts, a morning routine starting at 6 a.m. isn't going to work for you because you're just clocking off or you're at the end of your shift. if you're someone who has ADHD, a highly intensive time-bound routine with many, many steps, many different parts, also probably won't work. Or maybe it will, actually. You know, I have been seeing recent studies about how time blocking for ADHD is really effective, really helps with time blindness. But I think you've had to have had some practice before you jump straight in.
比如这就是完美的一天，包含了我深知能让自己快乐的具体方案。这也很好理解，当我们谈论选择规律作息时，不同的职业、不同的性格、不同的人，适合的作息自然也不同。所以，如果你上的是夜班，一个早上6点开始的早晨作息对你来说就行不通，因为那时你才刚下班，或者正处于班次的尾声。如果你有多动症，那种高度密集、有时间限制、包含成百上千个步骤和不同环节的作息，大概也行不通。或者其实也行得通？你知道的，我最近看到一些研究，关于时间块划分法对多动症非常有效，能切实帮助克服时间盲视。但我想，在直接上手之前，你大概得先做一些练习。
My point is really this. You've got to choose what's best for you. Like, I do not wake up at 6 a.m. because I know that I am most productive between 7 and 10 p.m. So I want to prioritize that time period of my life, knowing that that's where my peak performance is, rather than trying to fit myself into the circle or the box of someone else's routine. So coming back to what we were talking before, how do I choose my routine? How do I start with the structure? Once you've kind of decided morning or night routine, the first thing I really want you to do is reflect on one thing that you are trying to prioritize.
我的重点其实是这样的：你必须选择最适合自己的方式。比如，我不会在早上6点起床，因为我知道自己在晚上7点到10点之间效率最高。所以我更想优先利用那段时间，深知那是我的巅峰表现期，而不是强行把自己塞进别人作息的条条框框里。所以回到我们刚才讨论的话题，我该如何选择自己的作息？我该如何开始建立结构？一旦你决定了是早起作息还是晚睡作息，我希望你做的第一件事，就是反思一下你目前正在努力优先处理的一件事。
in your life right now. Some examples. Is it exercising? Is it limiting social media time? Is it reading more? Is it feeling more rested? All of these sound amazing. I want you to choose just one. That is going to become the centerpiece upon which you are going to build everything else around. So let's say your biggest goal is to get more daily movement. You know, you work in an office, you sit all day, you're feeling sluggish. If that's your priority, then I want you to assess your day. for where there is the most time loss by doing a quick time audit. Basically, when you do a time audit, it's really meant to help you identify where you are perhaps dedicating too much time to what I call lost hours. So lost hours include time scrolling your phone, time sleeping past the point of restoration,
你目前生活中的重点是什么。举几个例子。是锻炼身体吗？是限制社交媒体的使用时间吗？是读更多的书吗？还是想感觉更有精神？这些听起来都很棒。但我希望你只选一个。这将成为你的核心，你将围绕它来构建其他的一切。所以，假设你最大的目标是增加日常活动量。你知道的，你在办公室上班，整天坐着，感觉浑身没劲。如果这是你的首要任务，那么我希望你通过快速的时间审计来评估自己的一天，看看哪个时间段浪费的时间最多。基本上，当你进行时间审计时，它真正的目的是帮你找出，你可能把太多时间花在了我所谓的“消磨时间”上。所以，消磨时间包括刷手机的时间、睡过头超过恢复体力所需的时间、
time spent in bed, time spent procrastinating. Of course, sometimes, you know, having a bit of bed rot or brain rot is helpful. Sometimes you really do just need to turn your brain off in front of the TV for a little while. Sometimes you have slept 10 hours because you really need it. But if that means, if that is consistently and it's not actually helping you, that is where your lost hours are probably sitting. So where on your day do you have the most lost hours? Is it morning, middle of the day or afternoon slash evening?
躺在床上的时间、拖延的时间。当然，有时候，你知道的，稍微“躺平”或让大脑放空是有帮助的。有时你确实只需要在电视机前关掉大脑一会儿。有时你睡了10个小时是因为你真的需要。但如果这意味着——如果这种情况持续发生且对你毫无帮助，那么你的“消磨时间”很可能就出在这里。那么，你一天中的哪个时间段“消磨时间”最多？是早晨、中午，还是下午加傍晚？
let's say for this example it's evening that is where you're going to choose your first routine where you have that priority that you want to get done you're going to put it where there is most time wasted pretty simple this also really helps you work with what you have instead of feeling like you need to eat into more valuable things in order to get stuff done like working out like you're finding space that you already have available like i said before we are also going to structure our routine for seven to eight hours of sleep so no where do you want to, like where do you want to sleep? Are you someone who prefers an early night or asleep in?
我们以这个例子来说，假设是傍晚。那就是你要选择建立第一个作息的地方，也就是你有那个想要完成的优先任务的地方。你要把它放在浪费时间最多的地方，这很简单。这也确实能帮你在现有的基础上发挥，而不是觉得为了完成事情（比如锻炼），你需要侵占更有价值的事情的时间。这就好比你在寻找自己原本就拥有的空间。正如我之前所说，我们还要把作息结构规划为7到8个小时的睡眠。所以，你究竟想在哪里睡觉？你是那种喜欢早睡的人，还是喜欢睡懒觉的人？
In this case, we're doing evening. So we are perhaps, I'm guessing, considering a bit of a sleep in and choose where you want to insert your major habit, what you want your bedtime to be, and work backwards from that time to kind of create the structure. So I want to go to bed at 11 p.m. My major habit is that I want to work out. I want to work out at least three hours before bed. I'm going to have this really nice evening afternoon routine
在这种情况下，我们选择的是傍晚。所以我想，我们大概会考虑稍微晚起一点，然后选定你想把主要习惯插入哪个时间段，确定你希望的就寝时间，并从那个时间开始倒推，以此来构建结构。所以，我想晚上11点睡觉。我的主要习惯是我想锻炼。我想在睡前至少三小时锻炼。我要有一个非常美好的傍晚或下午作息，
working towards this idea that I will be in bed at a certain time. So this is kind of how I do it. If I know I want to go to bed at a certain time, I know I want my teeth to be brushed, my face to be washed, my sheets to be all cozy, my water to be filled by another time. So let's say an hour.
朝着这个目标努力，即我在某个特定时间上床睡觉。所以这就是我的做法。如果我知道我想在某个特定时间睡觉，我就知道我希望在另一个时间之前刷好牙、洗好脸、把床单铺得舒舒服服、把水杯加满。所以，比如提前一个小时。
And I know I want to get home from the gym and do X, Y, Z, for maybe like 30 minutes, have a bit of a decompress. So my routine would be, okay, I finish work, I go home, I make dinner, I go to the gym for an hour, even if the workout is terrible, I stay for an hour, then I come home and then I start that secondary part of my morning routine that kind of caps off the night. But really, the one thing I want to ensure that you get out of this is that we are focusing on only one habit that we consider tier one. So your tier one habit is the one thing you cannot compromise on.
而且我知道我想从健身房回家，然后做张三、李四、王五的事，大概持续30分钟，稍微放松一下。所以我的作息会是这样的：我下班回家，做晚饭，去健身房锻炼一小时，哪怕当天的状态差透了，我也坚持待上一小时；然后回家，开始我那套早间作息的第二部分，用来给夜晚收个尾。但说实话，我最希望你从中领悟到的是，我们只专注于一个被我们视为“一级”的习惯。所以，你的一级习惯就是你绝不能妥协的那件事。
As you get better at not compromising on it, then you can start adding in tier two habits, like a five-minute meditation or a 15-minute journal practice or of sunlight. The reason this is important to secure is that even if you fail a tier two habit, your day will still be a victory if you get your tier one habit done. And this really avoids like a very unhealthy all or nothing thinking mentality of needing to have a routine with a thousand steps. We really want to standardize one activity before we add or optimize other areas. So I say this because I see many people try and create those crazy morning routines. It's too complex.
随着你越来越擅长坚持这项不妥协的习惯，你就可以开始加入二级习惯，比如5分钟的冥想、15分钟的写日记习惯，或者是晒晒太阳。确保这一点之所以重要，是因为即便你的二级习惯没坚持下来，只要你完成了你的一级习惯，你的一天依然算是一场胜利。这确实能避免那种非常不健康的“非黑即白”的思维模式，即觉得非得搞一个包含上千个步骤的作息不可。在添加或优化其他领域之前，我们真正想要做的是将某一项活动标准化。我之所以这么说，是因为我看到很多人试图创造那些疯狂的早晨作息。太复杂了。
It's too complex to have too many small things that have two small minuscule, you know, time blocks. and hope they all add up because things happen, things go wrong, we're busy, we're tired, we want to simplify the process. Also, research from the University of College, London, found that on average it takes 66 days for a new habit to stick. If you have too many habits, they ain't going to stick. There's going to be too many of them that you need to be really, really loyal and dedicated to for, you know, almost two and a half months at that point. So if you set and you stick to a new plan or a new habit for 66 days, there is a good chance that that routine is going to become something that feels like a non-negotiable and then you add on from
有太多微小的事情，占据了太多微不足道的（你知道的）时间块，这实在太复杂了，而且还指望它们能叠加起作用。因为生活总会有意外，总会有状况，我们很忙，很累，我们想要简化这个过程。此外，伦敦大学学院的研究发现，一项新习惯要固定下来，平均需要66天。如果你有太多的习惯，它们是不会坚持下来的。其中会有太多习惯，需要你非常非常忠诚、非常非常投入，持续（你知道的）差不多两个半月之久。因此，如果你制定并坚持一个新的计划或一项新习惯达66天，那么这个作息很有可能会变成一件让你觉得不可妥协的事情，然后你就可以从那时起
there. Like I always think about it like building a house. You don't put the furniture in before you have a floor plan or foundation. This is known in psychology and in other. areas as the compound effect and it is a proven strategy from there we can also habit stack i feel like i've spoken about this before habit stacking feels like magic honestly what it involves is taking one thing that you already do and then just adding one more thing to it you know brushing your teeth in the shower listening to your lectures whilst on the treadmill calling your long distance friends whilst meal prepping. Remember, your time during your day is expansive.
开始叠加。我总是把它比作建房子。在没有平面图或地基之前，你不会先把家具搬进去。这在心理学和其他领域被称为“复利效应”，这是一个被证明了的策略。在此基础上，我们还可以进行习惯叠加。我觉得我以前好像说过这个，说实话，习惯叠加感觉就像魔法一样。它包含的做法是，拿一件你已经在做的事情，然后在上面再加一件事。比如洗澡时刷牙、在跑步机上听讲座、在备餐时给远方的朋友打电话。记住，你一天中的时间是广阔的，
It's not just linear. It can hold multiple tasks at the same time. I think my other biggest tip for setting up a routine is to romanticize your routine rather than feeling like it's something you have to do, that you must do, that you're dragging yourself into. I love the feeling of exercising in the evenings, so I can be kind of like all sweaty and like cap off my day with some final real push and then
它不仅是线性的。它能够同时容纳多项任务。我认为我关于建立作息的另一个最大建议是：把你的作息浪漫化，而不是觉得这是一件你不得不做、非做不可、让你感到拖沓拽着自己去完成的事。我喜欢在傍晚锻炼的感觉，这样我可以弄得浑身是汗，用最后真正的冲刺来为自己的一天画上句号，然后
I get to have this really nice shower like I like how that makes me feel. I love how romantic it feels to work late into the night. Like I'm like some tortured writer or like a hardworking CEO. Like I like that feeling. I romanticize that feeling. My friends who swear by their morning routines always tell me how peaceful and quiet it is before the sun comes up. and what it's like to really just spend three minutes with their coffee and just focus in on all the sensations. So that is really the second part of what I want you to do.
我能洗个非常舒服的澡——我喜欢这种感觉带给我的体验。我喜欢深夜工作的浪漫感觉，就像我是一个饱受折磨的作家，或者是一个努力工作的CEO。我喜欢那种感觉。我把那种感觉浪漫化了。那些对早晨作息深信不疑的朋友总是告诉我，太阳升起之前是多么的平和与安静，
Once you have your baseline secured, once you've decided on the major habit, once you've decided whether it's a morning or a night routine, then it's time to be like, wow, I'm so lucky I get to do this. This is fun. This is a process. This is almost a bit sentimental, a bit romantic. I'm going to move on from all the warm and fuzzies and many, many benefits. of routine. Let's talk about some of the criticisms because nothing is ever 100% faultless, otherwise obviously everyone would be doing it. And routine setting, routine building is no different. The biggest issue or struggle that people have with routine, and let me know if you relate to this, it's that A, it can be really boring, and B, it can be difficult to be spontaneous.
花上三分钟只喝着咖啡、专注于所有的感官体验是怎样一种感受。所以，这确实是我希望你做的第二部分。一旦你的基准稳固了，一旦你决定了主要的习惯，一旦你决定了它是早晨作息还是夜晚作息，那么是时候发出这样的感慨了：哇，我太幸运了，我能做这些。这很有趣。这是一个过程。这甚至带有一点点感伤，带有一点点浪漫。我将抛开那些温馨的感受和作息带来的许许多多好处，
The monotony of doing the same thing. Every single. day can weigh you down. It has its own name. It's called the Groundhog Day effect named after the movie Groundhog Day. So the Groundhog Day effect basically refers to the feeling of repeatedly experiencing the same day over and over again and how that leads to a lot of frustration, a lack of purpose, a lot of boredom, and it makes you feel like there's nothing new in your life, which can at times also make us quite depressed. That is the risk with being too structured and strict with your routine. The biggest solution to this is to not go overboard. You are not a drill sergeant, you are not a member of the army. I want you to make sure that you are giving yourself a day off
来谈谈其中的一些批评意见。因为世上从来没有100%完美无缺的东西，否则显然所有人都在这么做了。制定作息、构建作息也不例外。人们对作息最大的问题或挣扎在于——让我看看你是否有同感——A，它可能会非常无聊；B，它会很难保持随性。
every couple of weekends or every weekend. I want you to break up your routine every couple of weeks. Keep the foundation the same but make the details different. So the workouts are different. The alarm sound is different. The meal prep is different. The journal prompts. are different. The commute is a little bit different. And please don't sacrifice novel experiences. Don't let yourself turn your back to newness and opportunity. You know, missing out on an amazing last minute concert is a lot worse than skipping your evening routine one day this month. I know a lot of people will stress to you discipline, unwavering dedication, commitment. But you know, that's really not everything in life, is it? There should be room for spontaneity over constant
日复一日做着同一件事情的单调感，会把你压垮。它有一个专门的名字，叫“土拨鼠日效应”，这个名字取自电影《土拨鼠日》。因此，“土拨鼠日效应”基本上是指反复经历同一天、周而复始的那种感觉，以及这如何导致了大量的挫败感、目标感的缺失、无聊感的滋生，并且让你觉得生活中没有什么新鲜事，有时这也会让我们变得相当抑郁。这就是对作息过于结构化和严格所带来的风险。解决这个问题的最大办法是不要矫枉过正。你不是钻头军士，你也不是军队成员。我希望你确保每隔几个周末或每个周末，都能给自己放一天假。
efficiency and constant hitting of our routine KPIs. We also don't want to feel like we're missing out or we're experiencing social isolation from our routine. Routine is meant to help us. It's meant to increase happiness, increase, you know, mental focus, increase productivity. If we are lonely, if we are sad, if we are resentful and frustrated, that is doing the opposite. That is not helping. I just think that if your routine also becomes too restrictive of your social life, you will resent it and then you won't do it. So, stress, test your routine for kind of two to three weeks and see if, you know, it's causing a lot of roadblocks. See if it's something that will require minor adjustments, you know, so that you don't have to
我希望你每隔几周就打破一下自己的作息。保持地基不变，但让细节有所不同。所以锻炼内容可以不同。闹钟声音可以不同。备餐可以不同。日记提示可以不同。通勤路线稍微有一点点不同。请不要牺牲新鲜的体验。不要让自己对新鲜事物和机会关上大门。你知道的，错过一场精彩的、最后一分钟的音乐会，可比这个月某一天跳过一次晚间作息要糟糕得多。我知道很多人会向你强调纪律、坚定不移的奉献精神、承诺。但你知道的，那并不是生活中的全部，对吧？在恒定的
give up major sacrifices because if you will again like it's not going to be long lasting you won't see the benefit please please please start small i will also say you can and should have periods of your life where you are not bound by daily weekly or even even you know monthly commitments or protocols you should have times in your life where the sole focus of your life is not to get things done. I think it's actually quite mentally healthy to sometimes give yourself space to just be a little bit free and to just wake with the sun, go down with the sun, to let yourself do what suits your rhythms best without feeling like you have to drag yourself from task to task. It feels, you know, quite human. And I know a lot of us look at that and they're like, wow,
效率和不断达成作息关键绩效指标（KPI）之外，应该留出随性的空间。我们也不希望因为作息而觉得自己错过了什么，或者体验到了社交孤立。作息是为了帮助我们。它是为了增加幸福感、增加（你知道的）心理专注度、增加生产力。如果我们感到孤独、难过、怨恨和沮丧，那起到的就是反作用。那毫无帮助。我只是觉得，如果你的作息对你的社交生活变得过于限制，你就会对它产生怨恨，然后你便不会去执行了。所以，用两到三周的时间来压力测试一下你的作息，看看它（你知道的）是否会造成很多障碍。看看它是否需要进行微小的调整（你知道的），这样你就不必
I don't think I could have that relaxed attitude with the job I have or with the life I have. But you do have the weekend and you do have space during the holidays. Like obviously that's what holidays are made for is to break you out of routine. That gives you the necessary newness and freshness to go back with renewed vigor and dedication to the structure of, you know, a more monotonous life. So please, life is not all about having routine. It's not all about having structure. it definitely does help us and there is a lot of reasons why we should hold ourselves accountable
做出重大的牺牲。因为如果你必须做出牺牲，同样地（就像我说的）它就不会持久，你也看不到好处。求求你了，请从小事做起！我还要说的是，在你的生活中，你可以也应该有一些时期，是不受日常、每周甚至每月（你知道的）承诺或协议束缚的。你的生活中应该有这样一些时刻，生活的唯一焦点不是把事情做完。我认为，偶尔给自己留出一点空间，只是单纯地获得一点自由，随着日出而作、随着日落而息，让自己去做最适合自己生理节律的事，而不必觉得非得拖着自己从一个任务赶到另一个任务，这其实在心理上是非常健康的。这感觉（你知道的）相当有人情味。我知道我们当中的许多人看到这一点会觉得：哇，
and a lot of other strategies like time blocking or time management that also fits in with this but hopefully this is like a basic instruction on how to get started hopefully this is convinced you of why you need a small routine with just a couple of things specifically a wake-up time specifically one core habit and you can kind of build it out from there again i appreciate that you've listened this far. If you have, the emoji, I want you to leave in the comments is an alarm clock. If you want to detail your routine in the comments, I am fascinated by it. I cannot wait to read them. I love seeing what people do because they can be so niche and so specific to the individual. So drop like a couple hours of your morning routine or your evening routine or
以我目前的工作或生活，我可做不到这种轻松随意的态度。但你确实有周末，你在假期里也确实有空间。显而易见，假期就是为了让你打破日常作息而设立的。这赋予了你必要的新颖感和新鲜感，让你能以焕发的热情和奉献精神，重新回归到（你知道的）那种更加单调的生活结构中去。所以求求你了，生活并不完全是关于拥有作息。它并不完全是关于拥有结构。作息确实对我们有帮助，而且有很多理由让我们对自己负责，
your daily routine down below, extra points if they're interesting, but also just as many points if They're just plain off because we can all get some inspiration from that. Make sure if you have someone who you know who might like this episode that you send them a link that is how it helps. This is how the show really grows and reaches new ears, reaches new audiences, reaches new people. Also follow us along on Instagram at that psychology podcast if you have further interesting questions, thoughts, feelings about this episode. Or you want to just suggest a new episode, you can just shoot me a message. I do, you know, infamously do a lot of episodes that are suggested by listeners. So if you want that to potentially be you, we'll see you over there.
还有许多其他策略，比如时间块划分或时间管理，它们也能与此契合，但希望这只是一个关于如何入门的基础指导。希望这能说服你，为什么你需要一个只包含几项内容的小型作息——具体来说是一个起床时间，具体来说是一个核心习惯——然后你就可以在此基础上进行扩展。再次感谢你听到了这里。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在评论区留下的表情符号是一个闹钟。如果你想在评论区详细说说你的作息，我对它着迷极了。我等不及要读一读了。我喜欢看人们都在做些什么，因为它们可以非常小众，并且对个人而言非常具体。所以，在下方留下你早晨作息、晚间作息或日常作息中几个小时的安排吧，如果它们很有趣会有额外加分，但即使它们只是平平无奇，也同样能加分，因为我们所有人都能从中获得一些灵感。如果你认识某位可能会喜欢这一集的朋友，请确保把链接发给他，这才是提供帮助的方式。这才是节目真正成长并触达新耳朵、触达新受众、触达新听众的途径。如果你对这一集有更多有趣的疑问、想法、感受，或者你只是想推荐一个新节目，也可以在Instagram上关注我们：@thatpsychologypodcast，直接给我发私信。众所周知，我做了很多由听众建议的节目。所以如果你希望那个人潜在地成为你，我们在那边等你哦。
And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere. but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
下次节目见之前，请注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再次畅谈。嘿，各位好！你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全地进行的坦诚对话。但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。奥恩斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·奥恩斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《深陷爱河》。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练的迹象，以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中培养韧性的方法。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。播客名称就是数字2。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the little bit of you, I got you. Back at it podcast. From 1979,
我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。收听播客《好姐妹》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。关于你的一点点，我懂的。返回播客。从1979年开始，
that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
那对我和说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
并试图弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行和最喜欢的作家一起从那个时期幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
This is an Heart Podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是iHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。